The joe rogan experience,
but,
uh,
I actually found out about you through Kevin boost documentary.
Um,
uh,
the,
the great white hope American drug war.
Kevin's a good guy.
Kevin,
uh,
you know,
kept an eye on me when I was in prison,
wrote me,
I could call Kevin.
He interviewed you from prison as well?
He did.
Yeah.
When I met with Kevin,
Kevin made my life a little easier while I was in prison.
You know,
shout out to Kevin Booth.
Kevin produced my first DVD.
Oh,
Daddy's comedy DVD.
I sent the book,
I read the book that,
uh,
he,
he his buddy road,
uh,
Bill Hicks.
Yeah.
Kevin's a good guy though.
Yeah,
he,
uh,
he became who he is because of his friendship with Bill Hicks.
You know,
he used to follow Bill Hicks around and record them and Bill Hicks.
As far as standup comedians are concerned,
like one of the top 10 greatest comedians of all time,
for sure.
You know,
right up there with a lot of people like Richard Pryor.
Right.
Even though he didn't live very long died of pancreatic cancer when he's only in
his young thirties,
you know.
But um,
so he creates this,
this documentary,
the American drug war.
And that's,
that's how I heard about you and I,
and that's how I heard about,
cause I had already,
I had already heard about Barry seals and Barry seal and his connection with the
CIA and selling drugs.
But I didn't,
I didn't know of any one person like you who could be directly connected to the
dude that was connected to Nicaragua that was connected to Oliver North and that
the whole chain of events.
Absolutely.
Yes.
I think when a window,
when Glen on testified against me,
he talked about
his balls to going on a fishing ship with a George Bush senior.
Wow.
When the kid went,
now Barry seal was murdered.
He had George Bush phone number in his pocket
as deep as it gets Migraine,
a tracking device in that phone number.
Yeah.
I know where you at.
And meanwhile,
and meanwhile,
no one goes to jail.
No one on that side goes to jail.
Nothing.
No one goes to jail,
I should day.
It's amazing they make the laws.
But how the fuck did they let you out at work?
Yeah,
they only you,
you went in for 20 years.
I had a life sentence man.
And how'd you get out early?
Learning how to read and write and study the law.
And finally loophole.
What was the loophole?
Well,
what they did is they charged me under the three strike law and what they were
saying is that since I had got convicted and all these different states,
that those added up to three strikes.
But what they didn't see in the,
in the law is that in order to get struck out,
you have to go to prison,
get out and committed another crime,
go to prison,
get out and they commit the third one.
And that's three strikes.
So we can't get you on three felonies before you're ever convicted.
That three strikes,
three strikes if,
if,
if safe hands.
And what I use is,
is a guy standing out.
When I used to stand out on the street,
I used to make hundreds of sales a day right there on that one block.
So I said no.
If somebody wanted to,
they could have gave me a hundred convictions because I saw different people
every time.
Right.
So I didn't believe that the law meant that every sale you may was a separate
conviction.
I believe that they meant just like I just explained it.
Right.
Because if so,
then everybody who ever sold cocaine,
what happened?
Three strikes and it makes sense because the idea is supposed to be
theoretically that jail is supposed to be able to really rehabilitate.
Yeah,
exactly.
So if you are unreal habilitate double,
if you've gone through two separate times and you're still out doing the same
shit.
All right,
well this dude's a career criminal.
This is his third offense done.
That makes sense.
And that's how the law was rolled up.
Even though I don't believe you should play baseball with people lives.
Right.
Because the person could not be changed at one time and then be changed tomorrow
and then his circumstances changed.
And he may be in a different position.
You know,
before you can start passing judge judgment on people,
you have the live in their shoes and you know,
that's why people ask me now,
how do I feel about drug dealers and I'm gonna and then it gets him,
they'd do what they feel like they got to do or what they know they got to do.
So,
uh,
before we pass judgment,
we have to get all the facts and live in that person's shoes,
the fee,
if we would do the same thing that they did.
And you're a perfect example of that.
Absolutely.
Now you,
you're away.
You went away for 20 years,
you find this loophole.
How deep into your sentence had you had already figured out how to read?
How,
how long have you started reading it?
Immediately,
right away.
Take classes there and I taught my,
me and my celly,
he taught me how to read.
He made me some cue cards with my ABC's on them and her cool.
And went from,
from nose to a reading my indictment to reading the newspapers to a Tureen law
books.
I mean,
you know,
for the first time when I found out is that I had never wanted to read before in
my life.
That was the real problem.
I never really wanted to read.
Right.
I mean,
I didn't see any reason why Jack and Jill went up the hill and why I should
know.
You know what I'm saying?
They didn't have it when Jason no money.
I would say some money.
Right,
right,
right.
It was,
it wasn't interesting to you.
It wasn't interesting to me.
But then once you realize,
well,
there's a lot of information that I don't have access to.
I became an advocate reading.
I read over 300 books before I left prison.
Really?
Yeah.
Wow.
You've read more books than I have in my lifetime.
Yeah.
So you're in prison,
you're,
you're learning how to read.
At what point in time did you start devising a plan to try to like figure out a
way to get out of there?
Well,
immediately I was trying to get out,
you know,
I knew that the guys that were going home was it guys that was going to a
library,
learn how to become lawyers.
You know,
they knew how to fight the system and then they had like guys that all they did
all day was sit there and study the law.
You know,
they would sit at the table while other people were playing cards and chess and
Domino's.
They would be studying the law.
So I got,
I got in with those guys.
It's gotta be kind of a crazy feeling,
man.
Everybody's just hoping you can crack this fucking system.
Got You.
Locked
up is tough.
What is the hedge to hurt daily?
You get,
you got like migraine headaches and you sitting in this concrete building,
I'm going to try to draw a picture for you.
You sitting in this concrete building is 28 stories high.
Um,
nothing but concrete and steel.
The windows are about three inches wide open and about six feet long
escaped.
It looks almost impossible.
But you know,
you think about that too.
Like,
if I had a long rope,
I could scale the side of the building.
So,
uh,
it's like a desperation,
you know,
and you're saying,
man,
it gotta be one loophole in these books because you know that if you can show
them in the book where they made a mistake or where the book says that they
should have did this,
when they did that,
then you know,
you got action.
So you're,
you,
you're getting headaches just from thinking and reading too much.
Yeah.
That's all you want to do.
You just want to stand them books.
You know,
they,
I got a life sentence,
you know,
when you've got a life sentence,
it's like this is forever.
You know,
this is all you're going to see for the rest of your life,
you know?
So,
um,
I didn't think that was fitting for me.
It's amazing that they convicted you for life on that three strikes law.
It seems like you should be able to go after them for abusing the law,
which should be criminal.
Well,
you can't,
you can't go at the federal prosecutor.
He's immune.
That's amazing.
From,
from,
from prosecution because he,
he's not working as an individual.
Even if it's been proven that he's corrupt.
Well maybe if you can prove he's he's corrupt but we're not because he
incompetent and justly that yeah.
In combination.
In your case,
you know,
if he does something to you,
you could charge you with a thousand keys even though you only had one,
you know,
and if you've got a thousand keys,
that gives you a life sentence.
If you got one,
you know,
you get probation.
But uh,
if it's powder,
that's a,
that's a thing people don't know about that.
Good point.
Not Crap because crack was in the ghetto and powder was all these,
you know,
other people,
these people that had money were using the powder.
Crack is way more illegal.
Yeah.
It was a hundred to 100 to one.
Wow.
That's incredible.
That is,
is that racist?
Very racist.
And it has to be right.
And I think,
I mean,
and even though they just changed it 18 to one,
I think that was still,
why isn't it one to one?
And that's what I said because they already proved,
you know,
I sat down on the couch with the guy who invented the law.
Really?
Yeah.
It's going to be in the documentary six six,
six documentary after you're out.
You sat down with the,
I've been doing that since I've been out.
I've been doing the documentary since I've been out and,
and,
and one of the things that I got mad about even with Obama and his
administration is that they didn't make it one on one.
And then even after they made it 1801 they left it for guys who have been in 20
years,
25 years,
they didn't make it retroactive.
Meaning that they don't get out.
They don't get no benefit from the,
from the 18 to one.
It's guys right now,
if they,
if they the 18 one,
they will walk out of prison today.
Wow.
So I'm saying if it's wrong today,
and you did it 20 years ago was wronged in,
right.
But they said,
oh well there they lost their,
uh,
cause you know,
Clinton signed the bill where you're 2155.
You've got one year after you convicted to come up with newly discovered
evidence.
And the law is crazy,
man.
Like right now,
say a few minutes.
If you go to prison unjustly and you do all your appeals and everything,
one year,
you got one year to prove yourself innocent.
Now after that one year,
if you don't find it and then a day after that one year you find this newly
discovered evidence,
you can't even submit it to the coach.
Oh,
that's gotta be maddening.
It's maddening.
They got guys in there that,
that,
that found newly discovered evidence that they can't even submit it for anybody
to hear it.
So when you went to jail for this,
so when you're finally in prison,
was there,
there,
was this the first time you'd ever been in prison other than the one time you
got arrested and you stayed in there for awhile?
No,
no,
I,
that was my second time when I got the life sentence.
I've been to jail twice.
So you had two strikes,
you had one strike,
two strike on,
right?
How long did you go away for the first time?
A five and a half years.
Wow.
So you were in the second time I was in trapped.
I didn't even go into that point when I was in trap because I wasn't selling
drugs.
I was building a youth center because when I did is I figured out what kids in
the ghetto need to get them out of gangs and drugs.
I know what they need.
So when I did is I bought,
I bought at the aid,
they need some,
some,
some instructions.
They need somebody to come and and,
and walk them through it.
Somebody they can go and talk to when they need to talk to him,
you know,
not talk to him once they already been corrupted and their heads are already in
the game,
they don't want to hear you then,
you know,
I already got my mind made up.
I know what I'm doing.
I'm home man.
But before they get like that,
they need somebody,
a place that they can go and,
and they could talk to Joe Rogan or Rick Ross or magic Johnson or Oprah Winfrey
or some of these other people who could teach them how to make money other ways,
you know,
because in,
in the ghetto,
you know,
the first business you see in the ghetto,
the first business is what the drug man,
he's going to be the first businessman that you see in,
in south central Los Angeles is going to be the drunk man and especially a black
man as a business owner because we don't,
we don't,
nothing in south central.
So you,
when you got,
so you said you got set up.
This is the last time.
Yeah.
When I got the life sentence,
this guy called me.
I'm not selling drugs,
selling drugs are on,
and I'm,
I had,
I hadn't sold drugs and six years,
seven years.
Wow.
How did you stop?
I just quit.
Did you quit after you got arrested?
The first time in five years.
I quit a year and a half before I went to prison.
I was like,
man,
I'm through with this.
I got,
I got eight $900,000 cash.
I've got property all over the place.
All I got to do now is make this property and stuff work for me and you know
I've got enough money to hold me off for awhile.
I'm through with it.
So I walked away from the game.
So I'm confused as on your timeline here because when you were 20 years old,
that's when you started and then when you were 28 you got arrested.
Right?
But you did five years in jail,
right?
Where's the five years?
I did five years in 89 I went to prison.
How old were you then?
28 Dash 28 28 and a half.
You go to jail for five years and then you get out for,
I got out,
I got off for six months for six months and then they give you the life
sentence.
Whoa,
God damn.
So the life sentences,
a total setup.
Total setup.
Total entrapment.
I was not selling drugs.
Then they'll call me in a matter of fact,
he called me the day I got a prison.
Whoa.
He was like,
man,
I need to see you.
I was like,
man,
I'm kicking it with my mom.
You know,
my mom came and see me and stuff like that.
So I'm like,
I'm kicking it with my mom.
I'm cool.
I hydrogen a couple of days.
So when I finally going to highlight and he's telling me how man,
I got it at this price,
at that price,
I was like,
that's a good price.
And all this is recorded too.
So that didn't help.
You know,
they was like,
oh,
you were interested.
Wow.
So,
uh,
this went on for six months that he courted me,
you know,
calling me,
dropping the price,
driving a motherfucker.
And then,
uh,
one day he caught me and I was riding with one of my little homies,
Chico Brown,
you know,
I said,
man,
this dude just told me,
uh,
oop.
And she goes,
look man,
I can sell all that.
That's how I got started.
So I wind up making an introduction to the two of them.
She'd go hand in the money and the police come from everywhere.
So you'd never even got to sell?
No,
I never saw it.
So this guy,
where is he now?
Danilo.
Uh,
he's in Nicaragua.
Just chilling.
He's supposed to be in the documentary to really yell.
Y'all better check that documentary out.
It's going to be though.
It's awesome.
Date.
Now this Danilo [inaudible] had a cop.
That plan didn't you or hugs.
Whoa.
It's,
do you have proof that he planted to the drugs?
I know he plans.
You're drunk.
He went to jail.
No,
I don't think he's going to medi plans.
You're drove.
But he went to jail for it.
He went to jail for planting those drugs for corruption.
You know,
beaten people plan drugs.
He was doing,
I don't police it was a habit.
I mean he made money,
man.
Yeah,
well that's where the rampart comes down.
I mean for people don't know.
Most.
Most police officers at this point in time believe that should ignite hired cops
to kill biggie smalls and that,
um,
they also,
he probably also had Tupac killed and that he did it all under this,
under this rampart division cause rampart division was working for him.
I mean there's a huge rolling stone article about it.
It's fascinating,
fascinating shit that the cops were so dirty that the cops were working with
gang members.
They're working with murderers,
working with criminals and making money clearly profiting.
Well,
you know,
cops man,
they just like everybody else,
you know,
they lie,
cheat and all other things that the normal person goes through in life.
So I don't put nothing past him,
especially when you start putting all that money on the table.
You know,
I remember my first young guy who got arrested by him and they stole his money.
He was like 16 years old,
you know,
he called me,
he's like,
wait man,
the cops just raided my house.
I was like,
yeah,
you are.
I ain't,
and he was like,
yeah,
I'm cool.
I was like,
what'd you am?
He was like,
man,
I had like $40,000.
I said,
what happened?
He said,
man,
they asked me who money was and I told him it wasn't mine.
They told me to go.
So when he got out,
when I got with him,
you know,
we call the lawyer,
you're in total oil,
you hey man,
it was $40,000 at that house,
but wasn't no drug.
So he called and they said,
man,
with no money at that house.
Wow.
That's super common,
right?
Yeah.
That happened all the time.
There's no one policing the police.
There's no one governing the government.
It's a real issue.
They got the beginner,
they got the guns.
Well,
not only that,
they can change the laws.
I mean we see what the fuck is going on now with this country.
It was like every week they'd come up with some new,
even more restrictive,
even more or wetland law that gets through.
That allows them to tap your phones with no wire,
with no warrants.
Rather,
you know,
listening on your phone calls,
tap your fucking gps systems that could follow everywhere you go.
And they can do all this shit without warrants now.
And they do it supposedly under the guise of terrorism.
But it's really under the guise of making it easier for them to prosecute you
for whatever the fuck they want to cause he's a goddamn business and locking
people up in cages.
Exactly.
So that's what they into.
So you find your loophole and then you chase after it,
you're in jail.
Right.
And then once you find it,
Luke,
I remember that day when I read it in the book,
it was like,
man,
he just like popped out at me.
Boom,
go to jail,
commit a crime and get released.
I started to the phone to call my minority.
I see,
man,
I found it.
Wow.
So what happens then
where was discouraging what he said after he read it,
he didn't see it the same way I did.
You're a better lawyer than your fucking lawyer
come harbor.
Why?
I should get an honorary degree.
Yeah.
So,
so I just told him to put it on the books,
you know?
Then the judge went through her thing.
Oh No,
Mr. Ross.
It's not the way you said is.
And I was like,
can you,
she must came read if she can't read that she can't read.
So then the prosecutor went through his whole thing,
but then I went to the Ninth Circuit Court of Appeals and they agreed with me
totally.
You know,
saying it,
uh,
if they,
did it the way they were saying do it that they would lock up,
everybody would be career criminals on their first arrest.
So
yeah.
Literally everybody would be in life.
Here I am life.
Here I am.
Wow.
So nice sort of ninth circuit court appeals.
They agree with you,
they side with you.
Uh,
you released immediately?
No,
and I had nine more years to do,
man.
Jesus Christ.
Why nine more years?
Uh,
that's just where it was.
You know,
that's how much time I had left.
So you had $20 cut me down.
No,
no.
I had a life,
but they took me down to 20.
So the Ninth Circuit Court of Appeals cut you down a 20.
Oh,
okay.
So at least you knew there was a light at the end of the tunnel that right.
So then we chose happy with that.
You were happy with that?
Yeah,
I was going to need a penitentiary cause I was up in Lompoc penitentiary.
You know USP Lompoc help.
What does that place like?
Oh man,
that's a dungeon.
You know,
everybody in here got 40 years of better.
they mad at you up there.
If you got 20 you know,
they got to get you out of there with 20 years.
You know something might happen to you.
Really man.
Yeah,
those kinds of 28 years freedom you want to years is you're almost free.
Yeah.
You gotta,
you gotta walk on eggshells around here.
If you have 28 you've got between a unit,
you may have gone away.
Me,
I didn't talk to him.
They were like mad at you or they'd be mad at you.
They're mad at you.
If you only got 20 years.
Yeah,
that's,
you got 30 years.
They might be mad.
God Damn,
that's hilarious.
Hilarious.
I mean,
you can get hurt,
you can get hurt then just because you got 20 years.
How did you stay out of danger?
Well,
uh,
like I said,
when I got my time cut,
I only had to stay there like three more months and I was out of there.
So it was,
it was easy for me.
And you know,
I'm a well liked guy to jail.
Yeah.
They liked me.
Ans How was the prison that you were in initially?
The first prison before they moved you out?
Oh Man.
I saw guys get hit in the head with a on mock ringers.
Iron.
What?
Mock ringers.
Bomp ring ring.
The mop outlet.
It's this great big old thing.
My way about 1520 pounds.
Yeah.
You know the guy sitting in his chair and the guy walks up behind him and just
smashes a score with it.
I mean,
brutal,
brutal site.
I seen the guy get beat with a baseball bat and aluminum baseball bat and to his
head was like mush.
They had to helicopter him out when the helicopter,
I think he had brain damage stolen.
He didn't,
you know,
it was a vegetable.
Uh,
I've seen guys get stabbed.
You know what?
I'm taking a shower.
You know,
you hear this loud noise,
like just kept bumping up against the wall.
Boom,
boom,
boom.
Really violently,
you know,
and you know,
this is somebody's body,
you know,
like why would somebody be hitting the wall this hard?
You know?
And uh,
so I can wrap my towel up and I look my head out the shower and I see this guy
and this guy stabbing him.
And so to get off tonight,
he's just throwing this back and he hit everything up against the wall trying to
get away from the knife.
So it was really violent.
I mean,
prison is really violent.
You know,
you have to be careful,
especially in the USP,
the USP or when the loans are dangerous too,
but not as dangerous as USP because these guys don't have nothing to,
what does the USP US penitentiary,
penitentiary.
What is the difference?
Well,
say for instance,
the FCI,
you can't have more than 20 years and be at Fci if you have more than 20.
FCIS stands for a federal correctional institution.
That's like a medium.
Okay.
So if you could have more than than,
than than 20 years,
you're going to go to a USP.
Now,
if you go to a FCI and you've got 20 years,
but you keep getting into trouble fights and you know something,
maybe you stabbed somebody and then they're going to send you to a USP in the
it.
Okay,
you go up here,
these guys can handle stabbings.
So they're there,
they'll boost you up and then they got what they call it,
a low is for the guys.
We've got like five years,
six years.
Then you go to a low.
So they kind of keep it separated like that by your violence,
by how much you're getting in trouble,
things like that.
So the USP is the most dangerous.
That's the most absolutely African murderers,
life sentences.
And then they had guys from all over the country safe and [inaudible],
Washington DC and,
and,
and uh,
you been getting in trouble in Washington DC.
Then they shipped you down to California to keep you out of trouble.
And you know,
some of those guys from DC or really,
really violent.
And what they do is they take all the bad,
it's guys from all over the country and they put them in u s sps.
So you may have a,
a thing where guys are fighting over territory,
like the TV,
you know,
like the DC guys or the Philadelphia guys might say,
man,
we want to watch this program tonight,
the Philadelphia 76 or the plans.
So we want to watch Philadelphia 76 in the night because you're always watching
the Lakers.
So that could cause a fight.
You know,
it's,
it's of like territorial,
you know,
the way it works.
Did you get an anti violent interaction?
Absolutely not.
I stayed in the law library.
Really?
They don't come in a law library and fight.
So how did you,
that's how you avoided everything.
Most of the time.
And the only time I really would put myself in a,
in,
in harm's way is when,
when football season,
you know,
I played flag football with the guys.
I played basketball with them.
Uh,
but I always had a mentality to,
to,
to diffuse anything that they'd ever happened.
I wouldn't fight,
you know,
if somebody filed me hard on the basketball court,
it was my fault because I put myself on the basketball court.
If I file somebody hard on the basketball court,
it was my fault because I filed anymore.
So I would always apologize to guys when I fired him hard.
But that's just the type of person I am.
You know,
when I played basketball,
I don't mean to hurt anybody,
but sometimes I do,
you know,
I filed a lot,
but,
uh,
um,
I,
you know,
I got along well,
people respected me and I show the utmost respect.
Everybody.
Did you have to align yourself with any groups in prison?
I didn't know.
I didn't,
even though I am adopted by most groups,
you know,
they adopt me most groups and most of the groups in DL adopt me,
uh,
I mean everybody,
you know,
the Philadelphia guys that decrypts the bloods,
uh,
the dcs,
I mean,
I'm cool.
I'm just cold without all of them,
you know.
Uh,
the only one probably is not as as is is,
um,
what's that?
Cerenia hose and ham brothers are probably the only two groups that,
but it's a certainty.
I was Mexicans and then the Aaron Brothers obviously kick your k dude.
Yeah.
Other than that I got them on and even they got it on,
you know,
they would speak to me,
hey Rick,
what's happening?
But you know,
we don't hang out but they don't hang out with blacks
the day you got out of jail,
man,
what the fuck was that like the day you get out of 20 years knowing that you got
out,
you know,
oh,
hair by hair.
It was luck.
Cause you know,
it was guys,
when I was in prison it was guys who had the same issue I had.
It didn't get out.
Wow.
They will argue that almost the same way.
You know,
a matter of fact,
we are trying to get the guy who was the first guy to get a life sentence for
selling crack.
We tried to get his interview and his issue was,
it was almost identical to mine.
Just a little different though,
but close.
And he's,
he's in for life.
He's in for life.
And he was only like 20 years old,
19 years old.
And it was the same situation.
They used the three strike rule and here's the three strike rule.
But he had,
he didn't have three convictions,
his convictions and little different.
Right.
He,
he,
he did have convictions.
Uh,
he,
his was,
he went to jail when he was 18 years old.
He got out and the same day he got out,
he went right back on the block and started selling dope again.
And he got arrested that day.
So he wasn't convicted.
Okay.
It wasn't convicted of the first one when he caught the second one.
But they said it don't matter if he was convicted,
you had been to jail.
So you have learned your lesson and you went back out and you did it again.
Uh,
there's gotta be a lot of that.
He was mad at me when I won.
Really?
Yeah.
And he's supposed to be my man too.
He was mad,
man.
How are you?
When I had the same issue.
I said,
no,
you as a little different.
See,
I never got out on mine.
See on mine,
they took me from,
from,
from La.
They took me to Texas and took me to Ohio.
Took me to St Louis
all
before I ever got released.
I never got released.
Now when you got out was the first show he did.
Uh,
you already know,
man.
Been a long time.
I went and got me some
old girlfriends.
Nah,
no,
a new girl.
New Girl.
Did you know this girl may make like the girls like contact you like while
you're in?
Yeah.
Yeah,
I got a lot of that is cause you were famous famous American gangster magazines
and they knew you were coming out to as he has magazine.
Yeah.
They knew I was coming home.
They,
they,
they started to publicize that I had got a date.
Okay.